The reality is, I would choose the bear.
You would choose the bear.
We would all choose the bear. Collectively,
as the internet is female presenting people,
we all would choose the bear.
And I can't speak for everyone's reasons
why they would choose the bear.
But the reason I told my husband is this.
Because a bear doesn't hate people the same way men hate women.
And if I'm gonna die anyway,
I would choose the dignity and death of being mauled by a bear.
Then a scary, scary man who wants to take his time.
Because the scariest of bears
will never be scarier than the scariest of men.
And if I'm gonna die anyway,
I will take the dignity and death of a natural death
from a wild animal.
Then I would take the creative torture that a man can provide.